ah chief good job dude
I saw that this morning one of our
wonderful sons teeth no quip calm yeah
great sponsor great product yeah I'll
let your toothbrushes are awesome this
is a lot and less expensive than the
other one they're sending you something
oh good I need him I'll brush my teeth
with him
so we said they said they come to us the
sales department came to us and said
like what word do you want your code
word to be Jim and Sam blah blah blah
and Jim and I decided as a unit it
needed to be Tefft so that you know
that's how companies when they're
advertising they figure out what show
makes what kind of impact they track per
show so our link is whatever it is calm
slash it's supposed to be test but we
got the copy the ad copy this morning
and it said slash teefed and then we
were in the office and looked up okay
maybe this is just a misprint on the
sheet but we have to read it that way
because the company created the site the
extension of the website it is teefed so
what's the website again quip comm isn't
it yeah you're I saw get quip qu IP get
quip comm backslash teased so you know
tomorrow te EFT you gotta go and support
it just because it's a good product and
it's also teefed but yeah i mean i would
say for this one it's the chief
difficulty detroy you gotta do slash
teefed come on dude trying to make some
money yeah it doesn't it doesn't work
let's see you go slash teeth and they're
selling dildos there and there it is
slash teeth it actually it it worked
tragic news by the way well I was gonna
say it is a big coming in wrong it is
truly amazing because tragic news with
the sales department anytime a live read
is even sort because they they if you're
delayed at all in what time you send
them the live read they freak out if you
don't give them enough lead time with
when you're gonna go on vacation they
freak out they say this is where the
money is this is
this is so important and like every
detail on our end has to be perfect
or somebody loses their mind and then
when it comes back from the other side
it's teefed it doesn't seem that
difficult it's just attached look at the
guy's name his name we talked about on
the show a lot he's worked here for like
how long Travis Oh God
14 years he's been here for 14 years and
that's all you've made it to it in there
this is it rich as good as again yeah
that's it well rich to be fair Sam zoom
in here a week and a half to be fair to
Travis we did name that room the teefed
box we did the tea box so that's that's
pretty big come celebrate in Montreal
Travis Chiefs will be there yeah yeah
we'll put the tea box whoever traveling
International Chiefs box
terrible news by the way what is the
tragic okay that is terrible Boston is
sold out so there will be no Boston
first of all 800 tickets are sold out
two months in advance your bragging no
I'm not I just never knew Jim Norton
can't sell that out no wow months in
advance 800 plus take is what do you
think of that rich the chip I was doing
a show in Boston that sold out at over
800 tickets um and it's like okay
September which is plural two months
away yeah and sorry
it's amazing what you sorry you're doing
it on purpose
I don't mean to yes you did I watched
your hand you went on my hands if you
had a good guest on that night I don't I
mean I don't know sure we get some of
the guys there Jeff ANATEL used on their
Netflix show you know there's some big
guests see who they use I don't know
Saget play out Bob has a show enough
yeah what is it
full house no they're doing the full
house thing on Netflix first yes you're
right Jim yeah there's not not an
outrageous statement you made yeah no
why are you mad that they have a Netflix
special why did you bring that up no no
they didn't use you know no yeah why
would he bring that out no they're doing
a show it's a non sequitur I know we
were talking about something and he just
threw it to Jeff at Dave he said why
don't you get guests from Jeff and David
that's about good guest at those and I'm
like wonder Who am I gonna use in Boston
right I don't know but why does he bring
something up like that where there's
clearly hostility oh no I don't you're
trying to be a radio host yeah I'm
working on it yeah but he's actually a
legit question I'm trying to figure who
should I get in Boston who's a good
Boston ask me for a toucher but then you
know I'm thinking maybe you're gonna
help me but there's like no just go to
get the ones Jeff and Dave used not
naturally but he's pacifically said
netflix they did have a show on Netflix
you really resentful that you know
presenter oh no no you're taking it
wrong no no no step back Oh gracious I
can't believe that I would jump to that
conclusion no it's just
graceless of me so you don't know yet
who's it gonna be
don't know man no I'm not sure I know
I'm gonna get a warm-up comic you know
you should get his Boston Wade Boggs if
he would do it he might I bet he's a
chip thin he might Travis did you go to
the trip show if you found out Wade
Boggs was going I mean they'd be [ __ ]
awesome yeah he's a former isotope and
yes right okay and you know you should
get in New York because it's New York
Donny baseball Wade Boggs yeah sure yeah
anyway you want to take a ride down 95
bunch of hop in the [ __ ] back seat
Ollie Tammy baseball stories I'll Drive
you down route 91 you can eat chicken
could I ride with you guys yeah have you
[ __ ] awesome yeah he's I said well he
do is eat check out letting me check it
on my car
me you Wade Boggs eating fried chicken
I'd share with him absolutely I'd split
it he loves some chicken yeah that was
just a CD so that's what he would eat
before a game Applebee's has endless
chicken tenders now so I mean me and
Wade could drop off at a roadside but
stop somewhere with an Applebee's and
just make a day of it 85 that came out
that he was eating shake it every day
Wow well look it worked for him he's the
[ __ ] man still is
he's uh born 1958
aged 60 I guess he is 60 years old he's
just eating fried chicken every day yeah
guys phenomenal he stated to I did
realize who's that bigger guy I've never
met him
we're talking about Wade Boggs nearly
enough no no oh you know how you get for
the New York show
wait a bit oh my god if you can get Jim
Abbott although I don't think chip would
would make appropriate company I
wouldn't do the most dignified interview
no I don't decide how do you do push-ups
you [ __ ] hand come on kids aside
would you put it
do you got cut off by a train or
something yeah well you don't happen you
fall into a [ __ ] mousetrap trap
[ __ ] elephant step on it to get a bit
in that would be funny if he's middle of
a live show you just bring a local
[ __ ] hand you bring a local celebrity
out for an interview just for an
interview segment
whether it's Jim Abbott tell me
something Wade Boggs should be on the
panel I think Wade Boggs should have a
permanent seat on the day I just want
Wade Boggs to be his co-host I don't
know I just want to hang with the
interact with chip I want to hang with
Wade Boggs is the thing Wade Boggs is
cool he's the [ __ ] man all right
settle down
all right I just get excited we talk all
this Wade Boggs stuff and I did pumped
up yeah chocolate bar when I was growing
up I have one he did yep so now Reggie
Jackson yeah well that's why they they
made one of his I love the Reggie bar he
was getting close to batting 400 they
should still have your bat 400 you get
chocolate bar but if you do something
you know impressive like what was it 383
years - 350 - 350 - barks white
chocolate show me a shot show me a
Reggie bar I love a Reggie bar they were
good nougaty with peanuts they just
still make Reggie bars as a comeback you
think look at the who wouldn't need a
Reggie bar dick I mean rather have a WWE
Ice Cream Sandwich oh let me first they
were [ __ ] amazing dude I want a
Reggie bar saving a bar it's just a lump
of [ __ ] yeah I like you there you go WWE
ice cream bars I would eat one they were
incredible Bret Hart
I've never even seen them I like a good
chicken parm dinner oh no I think on the
break I'm not gonna eat now join the
show this is big this is big why do you
get Tom Brady when you're in Boston
because I don't I don't I don't she's a
huge chip fan is it yes Brady is a chip
fan
have him on would jizz out let him go
she probably would you okay why wouldn't
you have mine for what I don't think it
would work okay all right
Brady you just the guy you just said
brought him up putting your gum on your
coffee lid
you know why he's putting his gum on his
coffees ass yeah you know why else he's
gonna eat his [ __ ] omelet on the air
again no I'm not
then why you putting your gum out cuz
I'm done with it in the years that I've
known you you've never been done with us
without you done put a new one in I'm
done the flavors gone the nicotine is
out I don't like the little postive hair
sticking out the top of your hat see
that wide Wareham yeah of course you got
the little poof stands true it's just a
cool thing to do yeah he's auditioning
for a new Netflix show dem Dumber things
you know I don't Netflix yeah why is
your headphones like that rich they're
on ones on your chest and ones on your
pleasure I'm not wearing like loads
[Laughter]
let's go do you know who would probably
like chip well everyone in Boston way
bugs drunk Oh grog would think chip was
wild yeah I'm an a chip chip wild man
your wild I'd [ __ ] do a 69 joke you
do what what um what to what strong
kinship hit this if there's a [ __ ]
yeah Kronk's entire family would love
chip would it be great to have chip just
have the entire Gronkowski family
onstage with them and just have to just
watch the lack of chemistry pour out of
them do you think of your lack of
chemistry I don't think I think chip
would do everything in his power to make
sure that everything came to a dead stop
I think I think chips jokes would look
like George Clooney on a motorcycle in
Italy just see that video I think I
think that would be the Gronkowski
family and chips jokes would be the
truck can we see that Wow George Clooney
was riding his uh blue motorcycle he
lives in Italy oh he does yeah he was
driving his motorcycle there his
bodyguard was in front of him which is
very poor placement for a bodyguard it
makes no sense yeah
well driving yeah but you get you your
bodyguards behind you you know just to
watch your back but so they're on the
road and this truck is making a left
right he's trying to make a turn here
can't do it very crowded area we're
watching it here not that crowded couple
of vans come along oh wow you see him
fly that one holy he hit head-on so the
the he hit where they have to put a
circle the one motorcycle that hits we
know who it is
he went 20 feet in the air he head-on
and it looked like the motorcycle came
apart hit a [ __ ] dead stop [ __ ]
car trying to make a left
yeah the SUV was trying to make a left
around the truck that was also trying to
make noise making a left first and then
it went into Clooney's Lane yeah he hit
it head-on the fact that he has they
City I was like for twenty days it'll
take he is like some pelvis damage I
can't believe he is lucky to not have
been paralyzed but that was a terrible
[ __ ] also for the record rich frosted
just have trouble with figuring out his
right in this line he did why do you see
the car I was turning from the other
lane The Bodyguard moves but I mean
Clooney hit that SUV dude yeah Center
right he is lucky to be alive can you
imagine being the driver that SUV and
you go oh [ __ ] and then you get out and
you see George Clooney is lying there
and you go oh [ __ ] yeah how cuz he mate
cuz in God's eyes he's better than
another human knowing the bank sighs
he's better wow he really hit that
[ __ ] thing head-on yeah I mean full
speed no stop and the bodyguard you
could see veered out of the way the
motorcycle in front of Clooney was so
dangerous he was around it'll worst they
are those [ __ ] scooter did he hit you
van in the back of the front front yeah
it's making a left it was your back my
parents right and funny I can't write a
note van is making a left or right was
making a right it's a hundred percent of
left then it's the front of the truck we
could see the van Caillou's ego is
backing up down the road we could see
stop to go around no didn't to the left
he went to make a left around the truck
he went ahead on but you know if it's a
bad laugh right who knows who's counting
right he is lucky to be alive very lucky
Wow
what's the girl on the back no no she
would have flown off to yeah what do you
know she kept going
hold on yeah about him have a bite rich
you just opened it I'm usin I'm not
opening it as you opened it no I'm not
eating it now why are you opening it to
cool it off okay
I don't better slap my dick on your food
why forget the food so he's gonna be in
there he's gonna be in the hospital for
20 days they think they should first
pelvis yeah he's pretty lucky eating you
I've seen motorcycle accident footage
it's the worst yeah all you do is break
your pelvis you know as shitty as that
is you are you are getting out ahead
yeah I mean I don't know how bad it is
it the fact that it's only 20 days is
incredible yeah it is it is incredible I
hope that at this point he started rich
what do you think yeah what do you do it
yeah did you see him
no what do you think what do you think I
would think I can't hear you oh your
mouth full yeah you know 20 days is
nothing after so an accident like that
yeah he's like yet he's lucky he's not
you know right you're getting hang on
the mic well he didn't break to pelvises
yeah no I had time to think about it all
that chewing time you went with to
pelvises anymore no you're right you're
right yeah I hope that he stops riding
motorcycles after this no more scooter
you hope that is easy why for me yeah do
you worry about him I don't think people
should be writing these motorcycles and
scooters are easy to fix
I have the worst accidents I've seen on
that website or all motorcycle accident
I was the last time you rode a
motorcycle last time yeah I never in my
life I'd be to say you know what I would
get is one of those three we
Detroit napkin over a feat that chic
full of egg and sausage no I don't need
sausage she met afford a mouthful of egg
and sauces seed and sausage yeah says
when he meets a young boy in a rest area
give daddy some breakfast yeah I'm
looking for an egg and sausage wrap gone
now what happened to you two we've been
waiting for you two I would never try a
motor set on my age but I would get
maybe one of those trikes you know with
the big giant ones well you know I
wonder what people would say when they
saw you going by on a trike or trying
them up what what were you gonna say I'm
different right what do you have two
other pieces of gum on top of these
these are getting thrown out dirt you
went through already well you know what
if four rings on rich-rich does
everything in excess doesn't unless yeah
except succeed let's go to Dave in San
Diego what's up Dave actually hang on
for a sec Dave did you see the footage
what did you think
fell on the egg question he work on that
let's go to Dave and Sandia hey Dave
a real actually if you can hold on for a
sec yeah what do you think amazing the
whole thing I think a guy his age you
know with a great wife and a career
maybe not on my [ __ ] motorcycle maybe
the back of a limo that's right I
actually agree with that that's a good
point
yeah we will go to Dave and San Diego
Dave hey guys I mean the only thing that
rich should be bitter about is his
comedic genius that's right I asked ya
actually if you can hold on for a second
rich he caught what the caller said what
do you say online tell me what he said
he said the only thing okay yeah no you
should paint a sari but it's all right
my ear what about your ear live two of
them I know yeah and there's nothing
blocking between freely go ahead rich
what do you want to plug where'd you get
the roast in there where do you get the
roast terrible guests you [ __ ] just
the worst of all time now you said the
person in comedian wrong that's right
sorry Dave go ahead hey Jim you should I
get Bill Buckner you know chip chip
could be bill and bill could be Mookie
he's sucking grace we could act it out
yeah can't build a supplement just try
to get he's like no I'm not gonna do
that
you'd pantomime the whole oh I think
it'd be great yeah let's go to Edgar in
Illinois what's up Edgar when when that
good no horrible car crash car crash
that's you know hey I love you boss why
gets on the phone thank you
- what a well delivered line what a
perfectly perfectly delivered line yeah
oh did you see speaking of Voss and his
dumb breakfast in his food
I am could I see what I Hoff has come
forward I may have admitted that the
whole I hob campaign we're changing our
names what is the B stand for the
commercials it was all fake yeah it was
all a phony thing they're not actually
gonna change any of the signs that are
gonna change the menus and I actually
learned it did work everybody's talking
about it what you didn't know was a
funny thing no we didn't know you didn't
either yes I did
oh really I freaked when I hop I talked
to people there
Oh cuz the waitress is her office and
they told the staff they're part of the
corporate branding me it's right
you knew that day one no yeah no I agree
I didn't make sense but I thought maybe
the business was doing poorly and that
they wanted to just like boost business
or maybe that people aren't buying
breakfast um I I bought it [ __ ]
completely well they're definitely it
was definitely a campaign to try to get
people more interested in the burgers it
did work but yeah i-i've for a second
when they when they just changed it to
high hobb instead of hop I was like
could they just flip the be upside down
boss don't you think that yeah what do
you think of the Netflix show how come
you mention Netflix rich comment rich in
on the mic please what are you talking
about I think they're doing a great job
over at Netflix hold on I got something
caught in my tooth bullet about eating
with comedians on the radio that would
be good Netflix show all right let's get
this thing rolling I thought that I
thought for a second they might be able
to just take the P and turn it into a
lowercase B but then I looked at the
signs and they're all one piece I was
like they're not doing they're not
they're not sending new signs to all the
restaurants they're not doing all this
stuff so yeah all the menus everything
to hold but I don't think anybody cares
that it was fake I don't think anybody
was really interested anything is just
something to complain about and make
jokes about on Twitter for a week and
then it doesn't mean any
be done with it repelling got upset
Sarah Palin did it's over some outrage
from Sarah Palin yeah yeah cuz a lot of
veterans they like I thought you should
donate the money right that you were
gonna make for signs just shut up to
veterans shop and then Starbucks comes
out when they announce closet Oh which
one will meet you that you know nothing
that was really good do you think that
car crash is too long rich
perfect timing yeah Jim did plate a long
one how you can finish your bite yeah
this is the best thing I've ever eaten
in my [ __ ] life
pointing to deck rich you have egg in
your mustache be a really inappropriate
thing to say teenis
especially if you're still sucking it
you just hold it and say that to the
cabinets is the best best thing I've
ever eaten in my life
take a line from Boogie Nights Starbucks
has said that they're gonna start to
roll out this thing where they're not
gonna do straws anymore well it's for
the environment they're not gonna do
straws and they're gonna make like yes
sippy cup tops for the cold drink no
they're gonna make them out of rhino
tusks my wife own each use straws either
paper straws you could use why won't
your wife used to us because she's very
into the environment all that stuff and
it's killing animals and they take 30
years to [ __ ] drink 40 years exactly
what we there's not going anywhere
drink water bottles onstage paper
bottles paper bottles yeah hopefully
they don't so clearly as your own metal
bottle that she was all but smart smart
but she really doesn't use straws she's
just somebody quit like summer is only a
couple weeks old yes
whatever getting in July bandwagon
Bonnie July 4th was a week ago whatever
I don't know how long he's not using
straws I mean I see her what's in a Wall
Street down speak when you're quitting
straws like when you're like you know
what I'm not gonna use straws anymore
you've probably run out of prob
in your life you know I mean or or or
what what garbage what were you gonna
say
you're married to a dolt that way you
meant no you just you ran out of our
special interest you know what are you
doing I can't think of it then why'd you
start because you know what I'm saying
no I don't know we don't you know no no
clue exactly
Travis I'm not a causes have they
figured out in the tief box what Voss is
talking about I've no idea you run out
of causes when you're down to them but
when you're down to strong but it's a
good cause I'm trying to win points with
your wife
I'm not it's a good cause I've read up
on it said the only reason you can't say
in one sentence I guess you can you just
did that on one end the only reason to
quit draws is because you completely run
out of causes but on the other end it's
actually very good cause hey there's a
good cause how can you say both you
can't because it's a good cause for
someone who doesn't have a cause but for
someone who's ran out rich you're a
walking contradiction yes I am but
here's the thing I'm playing devil's
advocate and I'm on both sides of the
fence in life and whatever on this I'm
saying but you are on both sides of the
fence and wife had in the bedroom what
I'm saying is you're almost getting
quite each one I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna try to eat turn your [ __ ] blog
thanks Rachel Road [ __ ] it is room it
is ruin the audience the audience
doesn't like it you know what I'll email
them why do you have disdain for the
audience if you're trying to get them to
buy your special I like the audience I
just said you didn't have a lot of them
I said I'll email a mine it's all
negative about you are you kidding me
they're big supporters of comedy that
come out they buy [ __ ] sweater
there's just been it's too small as we
tell them let's retool management we're
building what do you think it happens
overnight it takes
race a year to ten years to get to the
we've been on four cops get to the level
where you're just doing pop-up [ __ ]
you know I think shows you do some where
surprise to people and do a pop-up you
no that's actually not a bad I come here
every day what makes way more Simon it
seems like ya know it surprise to people
you would people love that
I like the audience knowing what time
we're on and where we'll be yeah right
here in the studio I like you I know
what the acoustics are gonna be right
the Jim Norton and Sam Roberts studio
with the teeth box on the corner yeah
that's kind of where we want to be yeah
we like it here okay all right that's
fair yeah I think you know you switch it
up every now and then oh you might be
right I'm not saying that that's wrong
do you see this uh what were you saying
boss about switching it up mm-hmm
you were too easy cuz you said switch it
up but what do you think we go with the
same time just go hey guess what we are
today you know our only issues with the
time if we do it in the morning then
every now and then we get a total idiot
that comes in and eats his breakfast
while we're trying to do this absolute
boob yeah an inconsiderate [ __ ] that's
true even though the staff had been
instructed to not give yeah why would
they bring it to me she even told
probably right I would I would I would
blame who would you blame chief I would
probably put the blame on the internet
instructor yeah uh-huh you don't think
so who did you go out your fault the
intern instructor
none of them it's not your fault date
brought brought me the egg what are you
gonna do I hear on the air
it doesn't matter no they brought it
right before we went on the air that's
not funny
yeah that's the point you're making a
point they're gonna hold the egg yes you
have no self-control yes yes we know
that whole egg they don't know that they
dude that's you've been here how long
you been coming in for right now exactly
too long you know it's a prop it's a
little bit we just did hey it went well
no one didn't we had to make something
on it we had to make a bid because we
knew what we do we knew we couldn't
actually a few pounds on no no now I did
after I hate that [ __ ] big burrito
we knew that we couldn't do a topic or
actually talk about anything because
number one you're here and number two
you're eating so I would have moved a
mic if you didn't bring light to the
fact that I was we want to talk to you
about it you're a guest then there's a
guest on the show you don't move that
buff you on Conan I know you can't
comprehend that but tonin would you just
tell them
to another yes while you ate talk to
Andy for a while you know I'm in the
moment I know I think about my comedy
I'm in the moments I'm gonna come what's
that you're putting coming now oh I'm
sorry you can't tell I have the gummy
cuz I put it up to my [ __ ] did you
just say you can't tell I have a gum in
the gum in the gum they did say that I
think [ __ ] psychic [ __ ] are you
telling him both of you oh yeah you're
right on mojo let's go to Chris and DC
what's up Chris hey don't mean to
interrupt you while you're eating
[Laughter]
the roast that you have are you ever
going to make that free if you're
intending on trying to do form or
something like a free opening of it it's
a good question you know I don't know I
mean probably we'll go from where it's
at now and then try to spend a little
time on iTunes and then probably put it
out on YouTube well then why would you
say that people know that just wait
until it comes out on YouTube I said
probably it's a good boy how much is the
rose 5 bucks 10 bucks just support for
yeah go to borrows comm by the rose
trust me when I tell you he needs it I
don't need it so every people need it
yeah no no no it is it is hilarious it's
it's a very very good deal at that price
and you're gonna want to watch it
multiple times I would buy it instead of
renting it number one because I buy
stuff online just buy things but number
two because you're gonna want to watch
this a bunch of times it's a good thing
to watch you view buddies over the house
want to put on something funny this is
good
it's good stuff thank you did you see
what the Washington Post did they for at
least I mean they apologized but of
course they jumped on this story a meal
this is [ __ ] what happened there's
just this clickbait story a sarcastic
kind of parody story about the Green
Day's American Idiot being about george
w bush and it was a clique
paid thing and those dummies reference
that the issue is the story came from
the website click hole click hole is
like the onion except click baby like
the onion is full articles click hole is
just it's a parody website of all those
websites that come up on Facebook with
fake headlines you have to click it
that's right it's called click hole like
you can tell in the name it's just it's
a parody clickbait website that writes
fake stories as a goof and the
washington post saw that on click hole
there was an article that Green Day's an
American Idiot was about george w bush
and they cited it yeah they cited the
article amazon billionaire Jeff Bezos
paper published an article headline in
honor of Trump visit Brits launch
campaign to lift American Idiot to top
of the chart charts the story was
intended to explain that some protesters
in the United Kingdom have launched a
campaign to vault the Green Day song to
the top of music charts to coincide with
President Trump's visit to the country
the paper cited the satirical blog entry
that said Armstrong wrote American Idiot
about Bush because he started a war so
stupid I mean it's it's unbelievable
this goes back to like you know the idea
that you want a certain amount of
respect you know you want journalistic
integrity journalists get special
treatment because these are supposed to
be serving a place they're supposed to
providing facts right not creating the
news no providing the facts of the news
right there they're the ones that are
supposed to be making things transparent
reporting right so that we know what's
going on
but then when they do lazy [ __ ] and they
do it all the time and now it's getting
called out all the time I don't
understand where they come across going
like well no we want the right to do
this we're providing a service if you're
providing a service then act like it
you know you fall asleep fritz well no
sorry
but if you're providing if you're
supposed to be providing this service
they'll be [ __ ] lazy about it don't be
sitting there and doing the easy thing
when I found this article online and so
I'm gonna cite it for my article it's
not a source
it's I'm crazy do some research do some
research I'm saying
but yeah you're right rich well there's
so many hacked writers you know I
brought this up before but in golf like
Tiger Woods will take third place and
he'll get the main headline over the
winter right you know because because
he's got name value given a vibe but the
winner you sit now at the [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] yeah Tiger Tiger takes third well
what about me I took first because it
because they're selling papers right
because it's not they're not reporting
they're trying to be like okay if it
says Tiger Woods on the top of the front
page people are gonna buy this thing
those shiny shorts are terrible looking
Facebook
- I thought on Facebook I bought on
Facebook this thing that for your face
that sucks the blackheads out like a
little vacuum 49 bucks and never came I
got robbed
isn't Facebook patrolling what's being
sold on their [ __ ] website I got
robbed for 49 [ __ ] you want something
that would suck blackheads on your face
with a cloth bag what do you call
someone boarded told me it was good Oh
Patrick and you know you just saw it on
Facebook and got excited and bought it
Facebook it's like we're fake news was
invented who has blackheads at this age
wrong with you you're sick Israel he's
even dressing like a teenager he's got
Stern actually it cleans your pores yes
there's a [ __ ] little washcloth and
some say you don't go you don't go for a
facial
well I'm yeah a lot but I'm saying a
face show they do that kind of I haven't
got money only I'm one of my life we're
getting oh yeah what's that zit cream
they always have the pop stars do
commercials for oh come on teefed you
know you know what it is TV oh we're a
call proactive fact in 10 accent boss is
trying to weasel his way into a Proactiv
commercial for the kids like him yes I'm
young at heart I know you are and that's
why you got to remove your blackheads I
know but this stain 49 bucks in and what
do you okay Polly I wouldn't I don't get
me what up hey pal hello went to I paid
what baby how long ago talk to tell me
April so then just file I did it I did
file a claim and nothing happened in a
PayPal shed well your claims
done yeah well I guess if you got what
you paid for nothing they didn't send
you anything I didn't get it in the mail
they ripped me off for 49 bucks well
then you did the claim wrong
because if the if if the if if the
seller can't prove that they shipped you
something then you get your money back
no no I did it claim exactly as I was
told Nathan and it's a yes yes yes rich
no matter what kind of shorts or
sleeveless shirt you're wearing no
matter what you don't have black Heather
majors you're an old man who gets
confused by computers exactly no but not
when it comes to claims I think looks
cool well no I think he looks cool too I
does I just think he's a sorry it's a
summers day rich looks like he's gonna
meet up with Sidney Deane and hustle
some kids on this that's right he's an
elderly person who gets confused by
technology coach took you into the cave
kids that happens at times right but I
filed my claim saying rich Voss looks
like an adolescent tae-suhk a young boy
just exploring a cave with an older man
everybody's so happy they're alive no
one's asking why this man take nine boys
into a cave that's right yeah yeah I
mean look you know you're still my 49
bucks
I know you do you could do a lot with
and it's not the money it's for rings no
nice daddy for rings the problem is it's
getting [ __ ] ripped off you feel like
a [ __ ] poem I'd have tape on the
inside of your ring I got to get it
resized oh my god that is classic let's
hey Pizza bandit I gotta getta sighs
today when I leave here are you four
rings it's loose it's out of control no
it is it four ring watch looks expensive
it is yeah I bet
I'll bet sneakers are cool thank you of
course bread toast what the [ __ ] I'm a
headliner that's right show your wealth
what did free me always say if you've
got wealth display it through physical
means do you guys always say always
always you ever watched 2 Chainz most
expensive as to chines no no yeah it's a
show called most expensive astray this
rapper to change just goes around and
buying the most expensive things he can
find and it lets us know 2 Chainz is
very successful yeah [ __ ] great it's
not at all an idiot's way of handling
money no it is not no it is not it's
somebody who understands the long term
I think MC Hammer did that Wow
nothing like an old you making an MC
Hammer is broke Joe get all that [ __ ]
gold and diamonds oh I see it but you
just made a joke but and I've never get
past it it's like it's 92 I know hey I
like to be improv there's a lot of
people in the audience that you have an
older audience right why are you
pointing a raise do you can't touch this
this is why I get confused
- much when it comes to anybody who's
making jokes about MC Hammer being broke
it's gonna be confused by a PayPal claim
I get it 49 PayPal if they can't provide
a tracking number then you get your
money back you didn't receive your item
it's no I think I can email Deb [ __ ]
person right you know you have to do it
through PayPal yes I did do PayPal
everything went to PayPal losses claim
was just emailing the black head guy and
going like I claim that you pimped oh
well this company is some fly-by-night
they're probably gone by now let's see
if there's huh how long ago like April I
think oh you know I've got plenty of
time you got six months to file a claim
with these I'm in 308 claims over they
say claim is closed
I didn't know I'll go to my pits to help
you go to my PayPal account here but
somehow I give it out with a mask
absolutely what's the password I don't
have a passport I don't have them I'm
done with it I'm just going with I just
put you know what is these just an open
closed account why don't you just type
into the computer you have to tell us
what it is and we'll open up and you can
see we can see what you did and Travis
can help you with the claim yeah I did
it right
don't log it in but don't even say just
just right you're just right don't say
it and you don't have to save it on the
computer we don't want to [ __ ] with your
[ __ ] we just get a probably a PayPal
dude just go put on the thing and then
we will see what claim Sam do you think
you did it right no that's the point
but gates that's and the claim is dodge
it doesn't go enter the traffic you
can't see it from there do you have the
email that says that your claims been
denied yeah I might no probably not
yes I might no problem denied
it ran out of time that's impossible no
you don't do that you fight how do you
file the claim and then he found a right
nothing he's saying is making sense what
do you I want to help him you just said
you you said you filed the claim and
then it ran out of time
how why would they have a claim service
if they just don't answer them until
they run out of time but that's deep
ace is high when you just log out on the
computer so we can see you can see him
rich you can sit at the computer desk if
you want you cannot get my PayPal
account give the email you're using out
we're not going to [ __ ] with your money
you got a pal yeah what I'm gonna do
that even if we give it out all people
can do is send you money let's see let's
see what Mike has to say what's going on
Mike and Rockland hey guys hi use PayPal
all the time I'm a collector and collect
toys nice and [ __ ] high put in claim
to PayPal yeah [ __ ] whatever I get my
money I get all my money back when I X
only for a few dollars back like if I
get something and it's damaged
I ask for $8.00 I'll get the full right
yeah baybel I use paper I buy toys I buy
sneakers and yeah it's not as if I was
one of the best companies yes Jesus
amazing who invented PayPal no it's not
no it was uh it was not Elon Musk yeah
and and what's-his-face Jerry Shepard
Dini
yeah was Elon Musk and Jerry Shepard
Dini and then they sold it to venmo I
think yeah they wanted to call it a
shepherd Dini
yeah Jerry Shepard Eenie and then Elon
Musk was the one that said what does
that have to do with paying for things
yeah I can't do that yeah so what do you
do that's him
what did you find rich the guy who
financed all Kobe oh my god Peter philia
what is he worth a lot of money
oh well cuz he gets everybody's PayPal
money yep does he yes we're all good
yeah they're like what's the business
model here and they're like we could get
all everybody who puts money in PayPal
we get it oh that's pretty cool yeah
that's perfect
well they get a percentage of you know
every time I sell a shirt a rich Hossa
legend shirt they get a I hope they're
not planning on putting a kids through
college
yeah rich you not show you see me I'm
gonna do it I'm hold on
relax do you think reg knows that
there's a search bar in his email now he
doesn't I do know everything I do know
that what is it just come back to you
Travis was yeah do know everything know
every plate do know everything I'm
logging into paper which talks like he's
dressed yeah
stupidly like an eight year old same
thing that I go through my daughter
brush my teeth I know every day they
don't know everything and we all wear
our hats backwards you know okay which
was the style at the time you know when
still waiting huh I don't listen to you
[ __ ] ever
Oh baby boo-boo still waiting on that I
and that PayPal Queen couldn't been that
long ago that ran out of time I know I'm
going to PayPal dummies oh yeah you're
right I'm coming across it's very stupid
right now right here my paypal why
aren't worried why are the boys giggling
in there Travis I have a balance in here
let you know what do you know what it
cares about your balance yeah hold on
I'm gonna find it right here why are you
just doing the computer yeah I mean just
so everybody you do need mobile spice
you know you need to do it on the
computer if you're gonna buy the vas
roast buy it because you want to see it
not because you want to give us money
because the money will go into his
PayPal and he has no idea how to use it
it's not going into those PayPal over
here right rich just give you stuff in
Hana we have to do it on the desktop
take your shirt off and log into PayPal
man no I know I know
alright because going slow getting up
and slow I know
exactly I'm gonna lose interest just
login what we're not gonna show your
PayPal inform me nobody's filming you
we're not we're not probably we just
want to see the claim we might what is
gonna give out your [ __ ] financial
information on the radio
we're not trying to [ __ ] with rich we're
not gonna give out your [ __ ] paypal
yeah
Troy you come over someplace else in the
room go sit on the couch or something
just because apparently rich doesn't
trust you with his very very valuable
PayPal information
okay he's putting in his email which
we're not going to say no where I
already am right it's not live video
what do you mean by it is not live it's
pointed at me so any sense it's taped
what do they know that live what we wish
you were there's cameras in here
everyone can see where's your mouse
listen you do me I'm standing on a chair
he's getting confused by technology okay
putting his password click the show
button it's a nice long one security
challenge it's the security challenge
yeah just gonna enter that that's not as
easy as it looks
ok he's having trouble already let's see
first one is right correct correct
he has to put in the job yeah he has to
type in the letters so that they know he
can arise but it's yeah that's wrong
already ok you have to type them in the
way they're shown ok now you got to
receive a text for a security check next
now you got to wait he's very confused
his phone is still in his pocket they
got to send him a text yeah because it's
a different computer than you're
normally logging right it's very very
secure you got your code ok he's looking
at it he's got his glasses and he's
squinting very hard he's got a furrowed
brow as he looked in here yeah you're
just you're typing into midair you like
this Anthony
that's right that's right yeah
vos Anthony just said it's like an 87
year old trying to type something into a
computer that's a [ __ ] love him yeah and
he's right okay I'll tell him to scroll
all the way down by the way I just saw
what your paypal balances and you're
worried about us
oh my ok there's a microphone over there
rich there's a microphone rich there's a
microphone look at all this right there
look at charges Oh Mike okay no see okay
he's just scrolling through I know
exactly where he needs to go and he's
not going well I'm sure way to go trucks
he's only go back to the Haunted page
because he's not go back to the homepage
rich how many how many sneakers do you
return there's so many no no we've gone
through like 15 Nike refunds in the
[Laughter]
closed out oh my god
they closed it's 49 bucks where's this
[ __ ] guy no I bought it born in April
yeah me you didn't file
I did file on in April let's see there's
an ebay past April you think he knows
that you can just put in a a date set of
dates all you have to do is put it oh my
god there is no doubt in my mind that
you you could he would have found if he
you look in the wrong place one link go
to the Resolution Center and see if you
had a claim it's gone the claim is
unclaimed good right log back in log
back in and put your goddamn headphones
on so Travis can walk you through this
please put the headphones
yes he does you got 15 Nike refunds on
there in the last month they're tired of
you I know your little feet not fall out
of the shoes you just keep little
Tootsie's AFOL enough
keep-keep impulsively buying shoes and
then returning them it takes steps it he
realizes oh my feet came out of turn
like four or five pairs okay now where
Travis go down a little
time to laughter all down he's not good
with right and left stroll can you stop
stop stop he didn't see what it says
right right there resolve a problem in
the resolution center okay like that ik
on that okay
there's zero open cases click on closed
cases
where's closed oh it's next to open
cases you said it was closed yes
okay there's no closed wait scroll down
okay there's one okay why what do what
quickly you okay damn you think I don't
know I know what I'm doing you do not
mean hurt you don't hit click it I send
you something you're not you're hovering
click it I'm clicking it he finally
clicked it I click on the case ID the PP
thing okay you know p'n up another tab i
want to see what he wrote to paypal oh
hey i'm looking to remove some
blackheads yeah and i haven't been able
i'm a young man who's got an acne
problem i'm a student with some bad it's
it's just 49 bucks what April eighteenth
not received you sent company email it
bounced back okay we haunt when you just
remember leather seat my item hi rich
thank you female you're ordering on its
way as soon as we have more information
from our suppliers you will receive an
email with a tracking number that will
enable you to track your order if you
don't receive any tracking info in two
weeks please get back in touch we would
really appreciate if you could let us
know when you receive your product
please note the delivery can take up to
eight weeks if you do not receive in two
weeks get back in touch should you have
any other queries okay that was on May
1st okay June July 1st it should have
been here
May 2nd rich writes just read your
response
eight weeks seems like a long time but I
will wait rich boss thank you above a
bomb okay so it never came and you
didn't follow up by July first price on
the clothes it says please let us know
if you did not receive your order by the
3rd of June and then that's the last
message you microphones they did let him
know so where's the message I call them
you did not I did call them phone call
aren't recorded by paypal yeah you let
this go open up another to go I put up
another claim I don't have another claim
[Laughter]
notes don't log out file on you you or
you did the don't logout file another
claim you get your money back Travis
telling you you did the first time you
stopped responding I mean yeah
technically he started it correctly so
he can do it again right where's he go
Travis but he [ __ ] up well you gotta
find the transaction and then okay right
here you can just go up to activity and
and the company is gone they float they
flown the coop everybody okay wait two
weeks for tracking then it takes eight
weeks together they're just buying time
they robbed me don't worry once that's
one once that Prince gives you your
money back with all the extra money that
he's gonna give you two from Nigeria
you'll be you'll be flush again oh boy
you did that [ __ ] bit yeah it's
almost as good as MC Hammer we're done
with this right yeah yes sir okay you've
been doing it so I did it right no you
didn't you let it go you you're the one
who stopped responding there's no record
of you responding after June 3rd what
are you talking
and you go I didn't get my money no yeah
you didn't respond on June 3rd you
agreed to the guy I don't know I sent
him an email I did not get my money and
then they were like my product yeah
we'll let you know on June 3rd and
you're like ok no problem I kept trying
to email that company he kept bouncing
back there's no message on that claim
you [ __ ] up bro [ __ ] I didn't [ __ ]
up this is good because I'm an honest
person who someone stole from you're not
an honest price so much stuff for me
that makes me the [ __ ] up how about that
makes me you can get your money back
from the victim you blame the victim I'm
Alderley shaming because you don't know
how to use technology don't you honestly
rich you should not be buying things on
the computer you should be letting one
of your kids do that for ya
I like tons of stuff and I never have
you send it back you accept I buy the
life-sized couple pairs of sneakers back
a lot of them I saw in the PayPal do so
many I said refund refund really five
pairs back
one last month no well I care less than
a lot of a man I go I don't want this
girl I don't want to spare and so it's a
pair I got gentlemen skateboard pair
origin oh you know which ones I got to
know I got the bridge to you I got the
board skateboard pair of sneakers there
were [ __ ] nice ones but there was
skate I didn't like to come hey but I
bought to it uh but they I bought what
you buy were girl sneakers but I bought
it in men's sizes huh but anyone which
ones really the last uh the bread and
the satin ones no big huh the laces came
up the side that's the only reason I
thought oh my god I don't girly issues
that I didn't know that and then when I
got them to my house I saw on the laces
on the side so I returned to box could
you look up Jordan one Jordan 1 Chicago
win here Chicago yeah Jordan 1 Chicago
women ok that's the first one that will
you know yeah that one right there yeah
yeah that's what Richmond has bought
laced all up the side I mean the first
wording of final awareness yeah it W M&S
yeah I know it was a broad sneaker but I
put it in and look at the front of it
where's the that's the front there's a
hole in the front it looks like a
woman's shoe now I know why do women
lace up on the side anyhow well you're
right I got him and I got rid of I
thought I could resell them no wonder
women know to you know the store to buy
some the one you went to the easy said I
wonder where they can [ __ ] caught me
as a Freud you're not welcome back there
anymore become long did it take that guy
to realize they were no second he looked
at him and goes Joseph eight would you
say I go they're not fake this is from a
famous radio host rich went in with us
with a pair of Yeezys to Jim bought from
Amazon for $30 are those real or fake
these are real adidas yeah they're
they're 20 oh hey 20 for them these are
no $20 Yeezys from amazon that he wore
for his special very very fake
gave him the Ridge in a brown boxes but
they came in a plain brown box Chinese
letters Chinese writing so Chinese and
yes there was
wait did I get that pair too but what
happens when you walk in the store the
guy goes these are fake I'll put them I
go out yeah he goes with within five
seconds perfect you walked out with my
head bowed and thrown them in the
garbage but I thought maybe you didn't
know that you got [ __ ] you didn't
realize that we tricked you so you do
all prank but I didn't go donate these
or do that I went with it I got pranked
and it was funny right exactly
you weren't outraged or I was [ __ ]
that if I could have done that to
somebody I would have done it too
because it's funny it's funny it's a
good funny place right that's why we
love it half my day apart yes that's
what you know what hey I'm a [ __ ] I
got greedy I thought I could sell and
make some money I got greedy and I paid
in the long run yeah a guy thought that
boss was a professional sneaker salesman
he walked into the store and he said
where did you learn your trade you
stupid [ __ ] [ __ ] you idiot but hey
you know it's funny it was a good prank
and hey we all had a good laugh - next
time on radio right it's a fun thing
that we all get to have a the truth tell
me if those things were a size bigger
and fit me yeah I would have kept those
[ __ ] right there very clearly
fake nobody throws on warm what oh I
would have walked plane and when I play
tennis where are those [ __ ] ray
in Georgia
hey good morning eh y'all tune you
doesn't stop lettin grandpa buy stuff
off the computer unsupervised yeah I
think that's probably right I think we
said that about 10 times that's actually
right - yeah I don't think he's really
thank you Ray Thanks let's go to chuck
in North Carolina
hey yeah and you guys wonder why this
[ __ ] can't get a goddamn reality
show that is true something else that
Barney a body must be a saint to live
and be married in this [ __ ] oh
you
like a real 3m what I know you reach
them goddamn pianist thank you damn go
to the technical yeah saying you're
stupid rich right why can't I Jimmy I
wanna tell you where the finest [ __ ]
are in the world where I went on I went
on a cruise to Alaska and my wife was
shopping I witnessed empty bar every one
of them
Eskimo women not big old [ __ ] lips it
look like they been rolled up without me
thank you strip club in Alaska wow
that's the next Chuck Native American
heritage yeah I always say that about
name Eric we're gonna gorgeous vaginas
yeah they shot good that's a good
heads-up Oh cuz you're gonna fly to
Alaska to look at [ __ ] an Eskimo no
does I ever do a gig there I'll [ __ ]
go into strip clubs probably you'll be
working
Marc in San Diego oh hi Sam oh hey rich
don't trip dude I ordered some stuff
from street fashions USA and eight
months for me to get but it'll come bro
you'll be surprised but it'll show up I
got my watch in my boxers and I'm
totally satisfied so don't trip rich
awesome thank you Mark these only
fashions USA sends their stuff it would
be it would be a surprise if it did come
I would be like hey it's not coming bro
no it's not it's God you know what you
know when the email bounces back not
good not a good sign not a good also
when they're like yeah when we when they
can push you off to June third and then
you just kind of get lazy and forget
about it they realize like I'm never
sending this guy anything that's fifty
dollars in my pocket I didn't have
anything there's sent from Jump Street
you like that I brought that back
old-school Jump Street
jumps from the beginning we know what it
means yeah yeah you know a quarter of I
got a break ham you just perpetrating a
fraud but they probably I mean they
probably have one of those age filters
you know on Facebook you can target
am i [ __ ] you can target your ads to
certain age groups on Facebook so these
people probably go for the much older
audience that gets confused by
technology selling hugs it's not a
business I'm sorry I bought whatever the
lashing I bought came right to me
cool man they were [ __ ] uh hey you got
Christine in California okay let's go to
yeah Kristen Kristen hi hey hello hi so
I am an independent skin care consultant
I would love to send rich some blackhead
product
okay this was this was like a vacuum
cleaner have a vacuum for your face do
you know what I'm talking rich it's not
a real product they ripped you off and
it wouldn't have worked anyway yeah
she's getting the cream we can fit clear
up your [ __ ] you're a sucker who
bought a bad product nicely done five
acres I don't get it yeah I'm sorry
you're a sucker who paid for a bad
product from Facebook thank you I'll do
it on our podcast famous podcast my wife
hates me you know thank you very much
Kristen you know rich sometimes people
get paid for ads they don't just plug
stuff for just free I plug I like
plugging people I have you know what we
get some and I help people out I plug I
do whatever I plugged a bunch of times
the sneaker guy
Angela yeah good sigh so if anybody
wants to have advertisements on my wife
hates me don't buy them just send rich
process with something he needs right
I'm trying to get some more shavers from
Dollar Shave Club we I ran out you first
you know razors racers shavers
those are the people who use the razors
I want somebody to come over and do it
for me I'm trying to get more razors him
you know I got a run so I'm trying to
cut down on running so run what time you
supposed to be at the after show 11:00
well I have to leave here early you
[ __ ] waste they want to prep oh you
know the stuff you take just um I could
take
[Laughter]
did you uh Morgan say I don't think so
that's why I asked are you say about the
world copper you watching no France just
one right on Twitter somebody just said
Howard mentioned Voss today yeah I don't
know why well let's see if if Nick in
Detroit has any insight yeah I don't
know I made up you did yeah oh that I
wonder what Nick has hopes up as quick
as iPads ha oh you know some on me after
show he's plugging all right well if
Nick in Detroit isn't gonna talk about
that Nick hi Nick what's going on hey
boys how's it going hey
he's got iris Ritchie how you doing
Richie know what I was doing all of last
night I was laying in my bed awake
thinking oh my god rich Ross the legend
rich Ross the boss the [ __ ] King the
best comedian of all time the post of my
wife hates me podcast the man who had
one of the best roast fowl of all time
the man who's coming to Detroit that I'm
gonna see when he comes to Detroit is
gonna be on the show and all I can hope
for is this man takes his shirt off
tonight to make my day
yes will you please for your clients all
across the world listening to you yes
please take your shirt off and allow us
to gain some prices from your amazing
physique I'm not coming to the tree
where you are Tony last time I called
them you said you're coming to Detroit I
never said I have nothing in Detroit
Richie it's recorded you said that but
that's that's beside the point
I'll come to you wherever you are Richie
I'll travel across the world to come see
the amazing rich boss the legend go brah
the scheme the greatest comedian of all
time
then he please let's rock for all your
fans listening across the world yeah
amazing he looks great
he's all tan oh yeah it does titties
let's see unfortunately the abs are not
as defined as they have thrown him in
jail in Florida thank you very much
nikki did us all a great service today
thank you gentlemen
talk to you later boss you look amazing
you're in great shape your belly button
is protruding a little bit you got that
iron hernia thing going on you look
great you stopped talking to thin air
you showed me you when they go walking
to the mics yeah you look good and it's
weird too because an hour ago you said
you weren't gonna do that today
don't do it Troy don't put up something
that's unflattering to my create that
rich appreciate you being a team player
right that's right a team player
right I have to take it done if I took
my dump now right well so much better
well I appreciate you doing stuff for
the whole show doing stuff for Nick in
Detroit all of us I do it for Nick I
don't have anything in Detroit there's
one club we got fans Ridley said I burnt
that bridge
how'd you very unfortunate ah the week I
worked there I did about a thousand
people and the bad one table left or got
mad middle Easterns goes back then I did
some Middle Eastern humor just was years
ago what that you [ __ ] ABS
that's not a good picture
look at my hair it's a horrible picture
he's gonna add gym and say 11 the hair
is messy electricity here no it's the
hair it's just a little hair just a
little hat hair it's just funny you
don't have a shirt on again I just like
it
you bring me joy this is the face of joy
I bring all of us Johnny [ __ ]
latching that's the point [ __ ]
amazing that I am 61 you're an
incredible shape you seriously are right
and I'll tell you from the neck down you
do not look 61 now no my baby you don't
sound 61 my hair's a mess
[Laughter]
no next right next time we definitely we
we clearly won't do it next yeah we did
enough it's getting to the point of
losing its absurdity can I show them I
say I gotta do it
I'm doing on Norton and the other guy
nice I know I he goes are you gonna take
your shirt off
see you know and this is Bert's bit yeah
but Bert Bert doesn't differently like
you don't have to convince Bert to do it
he just ends up doing it and he shows
his gut off and it's like this thing you
you have to push and convince we know
your wife's gonna get upset so please
you get she's given up on me don't add
mention Bonnie McFarlane and replies to
this via there's another thing I was at
my doctor's office and he looked at that
body sculpting machine cool scope and
800 but what's your three sessions for
2400 you gotta do three no you know you
can do one if you want if you're happy
the result after one
here's your problem what are you
laughing at nothing man I'm a little
shocked youdo you look you look
unprepared to be photographed I got to I
got a little read the body looks good
you look great the body looks amazing
well I care about right yeah I I could
do a my face here's what I you know when
you do like liposuction or anything
mm-hmm
especially liposuction and this is what
I heard I don't know you know they're
taking they're sucking the fat out of
you right but it has and it's supposed
to not come back please do not come back
in that area so when the fat comes it's
good where's he gonna build up other
areas that Pfizer right now when you do
that thing is it not supposed to come
back lay in that area right but it could
come back another it can come back in
other areas but like some people just
have problem areas that people that
exercise regularly sure yeah so then you
just try to keep the fat you rich
doesn't have any problem areas I'm
looking at his body right now it's
beautiful yeah it's all right if I lost
ten more pounds and I work I mean maybe
I'm telling you right now 61 you're not
gonna find many 61 year olds and then
kind of shakes right not on grinder you
untested on college I failed my friend
who's a bodybuilder said you should try
this it's good for bodybuilding it's
good for sex but I don't want to you
know what I mean it's not natural well
how do I get it I don't know you're an
incredible shape for your age that's
just wonderful make you uh just wait you
call it
testosterone no it's not a toaster oh
yeah Harry Harry estas Tharoor I'm in a
hurry
it's okay let's all take a deep breath
and try to collect ourselves again I
think we all got very very excited when
Faust weren't sure and the last look
really good yeah we all got very excited
[ __ ] Jess
did you see the birthday collage we put
up for you no he didn't respond to it
I didn't she it was Instagram yeah yeah
it was your birthday we put up a nice
collage I agree I liked it I gotta learn
how to respond you don't know how to
respond that instead my body just show
me that you can get messages yeah click
them and stuff but it day only lasts a
day right when I there's this guy yeah
Angelo blando an Instagram I've gotten
shoes from before right
and I told him that Voss is a shoe
collector and he wanted to get him to
and like you know you talked to him on
Instagram messenger and I had vas had to
call me because I was like Voss just hit
him up on Instagram just messaging mine
Instagram my phone rang and vas was like
I don't I don't understand what you're
talking about
I don't know what to do he had to get
the guy's email so the vas could email
back and forth
I like email better and this kid who
sells shoes just sends me a bunch of
like crying laughing emoji is going like
by the way rich Voss is the only person
I've ever a mail dwith to sell these
shoes and when he comes to New York I'm
gonna do his podcast its grid stuck did
you email and figure that out we might
have done that on Twitter not on Twitter
on e on Twitter don't know
yeah Twitter okay I you know I'm going
to uh you know where you have special
messages on Twitter yes DM send me a
special message a special message yeah
hit me up on special message in that way
we could we could figure it all out yeah
that makes sense
thank you guys at Callaway I do you know
Callaway golf - best golf ball best golf
clubs are out there when you're trying a
free product uh yep yep she smiled but
she did look around yep oh boy oh boy
you know I'm not gonna say on top of my
game today but I'm gonna say there was
some good [ __ ] what she came in before
and she every you know what I'm saying
ya know Travis was just talking you
would have known if you had your
headphones on yeah I'm gay right
so am I
but ya know I would I would say you did
you did quite well today I think you
know what's better and we improved your
life you know we in for move my life
there's gonna be a fight another fight
won't be a fight a fight then there
won't be a fight who are you gonna fight
with Jeff Ross no I have no problem
Colin Kane no I have no problem with so
who's the outcault you know why shirt
huh your wife because of the no shirt
thing when she sees a photo that's that
flattering she'll probably get it
Quentin Tarantino is less afraid of
Bonnie and Pulp Fiction I liked it
great joke lean in and say they need you
and dummy okay why would you walk in on
our show to go do an after show you'll
do that after your you almost fell out
of your chair to leave your chair so
high to leave your friend to leave your
friend show so that you could do their
after show that's not cool I'm friends
with Julie I love Shirley that's good
what you're doing is not cool at the
point what I'm doing uncle yeah me
people only come in here for an hour run
out or [ __ ] I do you're our friend yeah
we let you come in early we love you you
know most people are not allowed to come
in whenever they yeah we don't invite
most people to come in at 8 o'clock
you know that yeah we're not trying to
get any to our guests why not
because we're doing our show I want to
came in today at 9:00 and took an extra
hours sleep you wouldn't give you what
in traffic I had a hotel last night you
want your 300 bucks today there's no way
we're doing the roast paddle last night
you [ __ ] out of sleep you do the roast
100 [ __ ] dollars yeah and you got
free promos do you exactly you're
promoting something I have to sell 300
roasts today deal look go to Voss roast
calm yeah
because as much as we as much as we pull
on Voss's chains
all right Opie
[Laughter]
it's funny my first is funny everyday
he's so good at a club oh shut up he
never came you don't think that's
condescending yeah [ __ ] you yeah you
don't think you don't think the others
shout down from the Mount no it was nice
we can tease him but will bless him with
plugs yeah alright I know we give him a
hard time a real [ __ ] carnival barker
[Laughter]